CHILD.
WE WANT TO BEGIN WITH TOM
FOREMAN.
WE WILL BREAK DOWN THE RIPPLE
EFFECT OF THIS RULING ACROSS
DOZENS OF STATES.
>> THIS IS HOW IT WILL AFFECT
YOU.
13 STATES HAVE THE TRIGGER LAWS
IN PLACE.
LAWS GO INTO EFFECT QUICKLY TO
BAN ABORTION.
IN KENTUCKY, LOUISIANA AND SOUTH
DAKOTA, IT HAPPENS IMMEDIATELY.
MEANING IF YOU HAD AN
APPOINTMENT THIS MORNING AT 8:00
FOR THIS PROCEDURE, YOU COULD GO
THROUGH IT WITH IT.
FROM HERE ON OUT, NO YOU REQUEST
NOT.
THEN WE MOVE TO A SECOND GROUP.
THE NEXT LEVEL, BORG WILL BE
BANNED 30 DAYS, IDAHO,
TENNESSEE, TENNESSEE.
THEN A HALF DOZEN STATES WHERE
OFFICIALS WOULD NEED TO CERTIFY
IT AS LEGALLY VALID BEFORE THEIR
BANS WILL KICK IN.
THAT INCLUDES NORTH DAKOTA,
ARKANSAS, MISSOURI AND
MISSISSIPPI.
THIS COULD BE INCREDIBLY QUICK
OR MAYBE A FEW DAYS.
THEY COULD BE IMMEDIATE OR A
COUPLE OF DAYS.
WE HAVE OLD, UNENFORCED ABORTION
BANS THAT COULD BE ENFORCED AND
THOSE THAT PASS BANS UNDER ROE
THAT WERE BLOCKED BY COURTS.
YOU GET 26 STATES CERTAIN OR
LIKELY TO BAN ABORTION.
THAT'S COMPARED TO JUST 16
STATES IN D.C. WITH LAWS TO
PROTECT ABORTION RIGHTS.
STATES THAT ARE PREPARING FOR AN
INFLUX OF PATIENTS.
YOU CAN IMAGINE WHAT IT'S LIKE
IN ILLINOIS THAT WILL QUICKLY
BAN ABORTION.
WHAT IS THE SEVERITY OF THESE
BANS.
WHAT ARE WE LOOKING AT HERE?
MISSOURI HAS EYES ON TARGETING
EVEN NON-RESIDENTS.
FP IF YOU WERE TO PASS THROUGH